hey guys I'm ratting right I'm Dan Simon
and we're gonna check out the trailer
day for valiant hearts I don't know
anything about this game all I know is
it's a world war one game did you know a
lot about it I know it's out right now
okay I've been told by multiple people
that I need to play it and it's
beautiful
okay well let's watch the trailer let's
do it
PEGI 12 the one not 18
we are
[Music]
she's like ready to the war yeah
[Music]
[Music]
scattered Metal Slug a little bit yeah
oh whoa Oh
[Music]
that is some of the coolest game
animation I've ever [ __ ] seen yeah
this one like I'd see one other trailer
this is not the one that uh you'd seen
prior prior and this one's like this
one's more action-packed the other one I
promise you you'll cry out alright I'll
check it out some other time ya know
I'll be fun it looks like it's such a
freaking amazing day but I've only heard
like amazing things about it so I just
need to pull the trigger and go on Steam
and grab it it's like a comic book of
one it really is because like it's the
hundredth anniversary of World War one
oh so this is like our way of
celebrating it in the gaming community
oh okay celebrating that's not a bad
term for it but honoring yeah that's the
better term for it it's World War I
World War one people mock me no I mean
that looks really [ __ ] cool I mean it
does have a Metal Slug vibe about it a
little bit
Raburn I said that though was coming at
me oh [ __ ] nevermind it seems like
you're doing a lot of things that are
more than just action even like you're
putting together to the [ __ ] metal
thing with looks like the Red Hot Chili
Peppers that's cold
she's healing someone to like yeah yeah
the only consistent thing because like
you play is for different people I think
the only consistent thing is that dog
that travels from each one of these
people Oh interesting
yeah which leads me to assume I mean
once again I haven't played the game but
each one of those character dies yeah
well that's no I don't know I've only
heard amazing things and so many people
told me like go we'll play the game so
long down that game looks like a lot of
fun yeah
World War one has never looked this fun
before I love our vets
well yeah thanks guys for letting me
know about that trailer um hey if you're
new to the channel you know you can do
that thing and dan has a gaming channel
so you do that thing too to this channel
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
try that time alone wolves 2:05 yo
homeboy said can we get a shout-out
thank you absolutely love your channel
and your lovely ladies I have sex with
all them including Lauren God keep up
the good work I have sex with Lauren let
her know that she's gonna [ __ ] murder
your face I know she murders my face
once a week people not would admit I
know the most literal of terms ya know
yeah and trust me I didn't mean it
literally - I'm just gonna go oh my god
all in 205 Seattle maybe B if I got her
right comment down below
he said we are you guys like multiple
people sharing the channel because that
would have make you a lone wolf
but his lone wolves interesting so if
there's a bunch of you who are lonely
together
you guys aren't lone wolves anymore you
guys new fiction name oh my god blew my
[ __ ] mind like the title of the real
rejects makes sense E or e L and we're
not your normal type of black-winged
pound lb 58 she asked I did a video with
my niece she asks if my niece was high
yeah baked actually off of my stuff my
ingredients that I especially cooked up
in my lab yeah yeah Bryan Cranston here
yeah hey Bryan
hey you're why oh and give me a shout
out in a Hulk voice what whole shout out
block wing l50 8 where's the Joker sorry
I have all my impressions of any tough
guy sounds like Batman
luckily that'll be busy yeah there you
go
you wanted that more yeah you know you
did you know you did
what's a whole shop Oh ciao pretty good
actually
we got dan a cover for you got it are
you Andre hey hey hey
would you give me a shout-out please oh
hey hey hey
Mario Andre yo what's up Mario you got a
cool name how many times do people make
fun of you for having the name of the
Super Mario Brothers you probably get
beat to death that and Andre mmm it's
probably black maybe it's probably a
black Italian nice nice yep nice black
Italian good mix probably got a huge
ding-a-ling there it is yep see ya the
goal is to always bring back to the
penis that's what we did Primaria what
we did right you hear REO rejects you
know your movie channel we should call
this the dick rejects dick jokes yeah
dick jokes are us the rejected dicks
that's what we should call do you really
want your dick reject though but that's
the idea
cuz Lauren God won't have sex with me I
was lying Mario why do you remind me of
this those ELISA just cat so is Adele
now hell I could even [ __ ] Jerry I feel
like I'm missing someone oh well it must
not be that important have a good day
Mario oh yeah I [ __ ] Angie yeah